what's going on ageac nation okay
listen you guys have might have heard us
say this before we're gonna say it again
one of our reward tiers on patreon is
whatever video you request you must
definitely cover and today's comes from
a man named Andrew Hayes who has the
fattest ass in the world oh yeah he
drops like it's best titties ever he
he's actually gonna be out here to
attend the live Collider show which you
guys should go attend there's not a plug
for that but I will say we'll be there
along with a bunch of other more popular
people it's gonna be a total blast and
Andrew he's coming on the channel the
day before because he's visiting and
he's a great guy to us he's been a good
friend and he's been pledged forever so
yeah he's got a great movie review
channel and because he loves movies he
tends to request these WatchMojo videos
you know the channel that everyone seems
to just constantly be on board for I
noticed most lists channel videos
everyone like [ __ ] about them all the
time now like every one of them what's
one that makes you guys happy they're
all good
they're all opinions and I like watch
mojos and today they have a list top 10
best movies of 2018 so far what's funny
is I wanted to make my own list with my
experience with the channel even though
there will be comments of people going
why don't you guys just make your own
list they get nowhere near as many of
you know but don't worry we'll comment
on the movies that they mention and yeah
it'll be a discussion it'll be fun yeah
to the real research people how many
have you seen welcome to watchmojo.com
and today we're counting down our picks
for the top 10 best movies of the year
affinity war is it number one I swear
every day so be sure to subscribe to our
Channel and ring the bell
to get notified about savory
for this list taking movies that
received their US release in 2018
earning acclaim from critics and
admiration from mainstream audiences
aways are good movie number ten
Incredibles 2 whatever Ted [ __ ] you
wrong things right
Pixar finally delivered audiences have
been begging for it might have taken 14
years to catch up with the party but
Incredibles 2 picks up as if no time has
passed amidst a showdown with the
Underminer
this sets the stage for a story full of
stylish action sequences and hilarious
character moments were asked a girl
literally getting wrapped up in a
mystery and Elastigirl is our best play
of course the film gives the entire Parr
family time to shine particularly little
Jack Jack whether battling a raccoon or
bonding with auntie Edna with
storyteller extraordinaire Brad Bird
back in action this sequel did not let
us down by any stretch of the
imagination number 9 first reformed I've
decided to keep a junior to set down all
my thoughts and simple events of my day
despite not having a single Oscar
nomination to his name writer director
Paul Schrader has established himself as
one of the most uncompromising voices
ever to grace the Entertainer First
Reformed is perhaps his best outing of
the 21st century exploring timely themes
regarding the environment religion and
military veteran suicide
[Music]
while we've seen these issues touched
upon before a film as surreal and
provocative as this only could have come
from Schrader's perspective first
reformed functions is a fascinating
character study of Ethan Hawke's
Reverend tolerable shoes either a martyr
doing God's work or an alcoholic
eco-terrorist about to crack however you
interpret it the film will stick with
you long after the credits to do
something number 8
Paddington - if we're kind and polite
the world will be right 8% of rating on
Rotten Tomatoes
you wouldn't think anything would be
able to top the original Paddington
against all odds though this sequel
managed to be even funnier and more
charming than its predecessor scoring an
elusive 100 percent on Rotten Tomatoes
in a poor stolen pop-up books in prison
breaks Paddington - serves up a visually
stunning family-friendly Rob that you'll
want to eat up like a marmalade sandwich
what is this sandwich one could even
argue that the film offers relevant
commentary on immigration as Paddington
fights against persecution and tries to
reconnect with his Aunt Lucy speaking of
which if the ending of this movie
doesn't melt your heart nothing we'll
need i say more
number seven won't you be my neighbor if
you cool up watching Mister Rogers
neighborhood you will certainly have a
strong connection to this documentary of
course even if the show wasn't a staple
of your childhood you might be surprised
to learn just how influential Fred
Rogers was in addition to lessons on
friendship and art Rogers was not afraid
to tackle topics like depression
persecution and death I've always felt
that I didn't need to put on a funny hat
or jump through the hoop to have a
relationship with a child
in addition to younger audiences Roger
sincerity and reasoning could even
resonate with a dark most notably during
a US Senate meeting regarding government
funding for PBS while the film doesn't
shy away from Rogers imperfections it's
ultimately a celebration of his life
that reminds us that anyone can make a
difference by simply being neighborly
it's a minute
for somebody to be close to you
number six annihilation these aren't
decisions following ex machina writer
director Alex garland keeps up the
momentum with another instant sci-fi
classic that's larger in scale but
equally thought-provoking and intense
centered on a female scientists who
venture into a mysterious disaster zone
annihilation assembles an all-star cast
that includes Natalie Portman Gina
Rodriguez and Tessa Thompson the real
star of the movie though is its haunting
environment which is alluring and
menacing all at once just as the setting
has numerous different layers to it the
story is a monster movie and
psychological thriller rolled into one
even when treading on somewhat familiar
territory annihilation stands out as a
singular masterpiece that'll be talked
about for years to come like they're
stuck in a continuous loop number five
Avengers in fact it's not one what the
absolute best MCU movie is but Avengers
infinity war fulfilled its promise of
being Marvel's biggest achievement to
date Josh Brolin did not disappoint with
vanos his long awaited arrival either
delivering an intimidating and complex
portrayal of a warlord whose power is
only matched by his charisma
half of humanity will still exist along
the way the film successfully
incorporates almost all of our favorite
heroes without feeling bloated everybody
works off one another to perfection here
reminding us just how attached we've
become to these characters over the past
decade
I'm Peter by the way dr. strange Oh
using your made-up names then I am
spider-man if you had difficulty
collecting yourself as the credits
rolled on the shocking ending you were
probably grateful ant-man and the wasp
came along to lighten the mood
you gave them wings number four a quiet
place it's interesting to think how some
of today's most ambitious horror movies
are coming from artists primarily known
for their comedic backgrounds with get
out Jordan Peele went from MADtv to
modern Hitchcock give three other
examples and emotional thriller working
alongside his real-life wife Emily Blunt
Krasinski plays a father determined to
keep his family safe during an alien
invasion where even the slightest sound
can mean certain doom the film is
naturally light on dialogue but heavy on
atmosphere drama and terror submerging
the audience in a constant state of
caution
number three you were never a taxi and
drive you were never really here centers
on a deeply disturbed man who says
little but speaks volumes through his
actions alone that's always been a
strength of writer director Lynn Ramsay
okay he turns in a tightly plotted
narrative about a hired gun sworn to
rescue the abducted daughter of a
senator Mathers turn out to be more
complicated than they seem however as
our suicidal protagonist is given a
reason not to give up on life
unsettling while also being unusually
hopeful this is a dreamlike experience
carried by a stellar performance from
joaquin usually Cleary said you were
brewed on the can be number two black
panther I never faced infinity war may
have been more epic in size to the
silver screen creating a culture that
feels surprisingly real likewise the
film flawlessly integrates identifiable
themes that ring true in today's
political and social climates at the
center of everything is a rousing
rivalry right here it wouldn't be so
alike if it weren't for their
contrasting methods and ideologies throw
in a winning supporting cast detailed
production values and inventive action
and you have a universal crowd-pleaser
that proves marvel fatigue will not be
setting in anytime soon silly before we
unveil our number one pick here are some
honorable mentions I don't think I can
stomach any more this guy you say love
Simon
guys you should all watch that who's
this that's amazing
number one hereditary it's Mary's baby
and The Exorcist
killed audiences to the core quite like
hereditary grieving mother who's either
losing her mind becoming surrounded by
madness Millie Shapiro is equally
exceptional as a troubled 13 year old Oh
make your heart race with a click of her
tongue where so many horror films rely
on jump scares director Ari Astor
demonstrates the power of slowly
creeping up on the audience that's not
to say hereditary isn't without graphic
imagery and while the film may not be
for the faint of heart it succeeds in
getting under your skin and into your
head I just don't want to put any more
stress on my family and be sure to
subscribe ring the bell to be mad at a
quiet place missed videos action going
on sure you won't be able to catch me up
press screen for that we did not get
food for a quiet that was an interest
that's that's a very tough throw that's
better than infinity work a little
you're kidding me look at that all the
comments are about it anyway let's talk
about some of these movies Incredibles
to like okay now my personal list would
be different than this for sure for me
Deadpool 2 would be on here at least an
honorable mention I really liked
[Music]
Deadpool 2 would definitely be on that
list for similar reasons to why
Incredibles 2 is on this list and in
some ways like the most superhero films
but yeah but different in terms of tone
and some audience all animation live
action however a big part of their sales
pitch here for being
on this list was the idea that there was
so much hype and anticipation and could
have live up to the first and it totally
delivered it might have even exceeded
expectation or at least matched our
expectation which is a hard thing to
accomplish and I think more than dead
pool too universally a lot of people
aren't pretty much agreement about
incredibles too
yes but Deadpool too does give me a
similar type of feeling as that of I
actually preferred Deadpool to my
personal opinion I am oh but I'm wrong
sure whatever I mean I would join you I
really enjoyed Deadpool too as well and
I actually like really want to go see
that again yes with so many movies to
see you don't always think that yeah but
Incredibles 2 is yeah that would
definitely be on my list it might be a
little higher up actually I really do
the Incredibles two kind of made me
appreciate both movies as a whole yeah a
whole lot and I had just a blast so yeah
I mean depending on a couple of the
things that come out this year yeah
haven't seen first reformed what I have
heard is that Ethan Hawke hates comic
book movies and he designed this little
sure he loves this list like oh man you
even said a whole thing about Logan
please gotta find the exact quote Ethan
Hawke on Logan so here's what he said an
interview with Philip stage Hawk
discussed what he saw is increasing
marginalization of indie movies at the
multiplex now we have the problem of the
tell us Logan is a great movie well it's
a great superhero movie it still
involves people in tights with metal
coming out of their hands now we don't
need to go any further cuz I don't think
he saw located where in that movie are
these people in tights are you sure you
saw Logan in the comic book no he's got
the eggs iconic I think you're thinking
of a different movie and then he goes on
to you discuss more about why he doesn't
like these superhero movies and stuff
and just because it's a good superhero
movie doesn't mean it's a good movie
right when I heard that I'm like I don't
if you mean something else but that's a
very specific thing you're talking about
and Logan is the nted is not that so
that's why I would love to see Heath and
Hawke do a reaction to this list video
right here yeah I feel like Logan kind
of least I get what he means but I think
Logan is bridging a gap of some kind of
me I don't think it's one of the best
films of all time but I think it's a lot
more of a film in terms of the superhero
spectrum that means some people like
that superhero stuff as an actual thing
I mean he seems like the kind of guy who
you know superhero in the association
with it automatically has some sort of
distaste yeah like a qualitative yeah
it's like these are fundamentally worst
movies everyone I know that watch is
Paddington to acts like it's the best
thing God has ever put on our planet I
have to see this movie man yeah I have
to I don't even care watch the first one
now because it's all gonna be about
getting the [ __ ] patties into this
boy yeah they were like some kind of
Marvel like the Paddington movie is
great like yeah yeah I feel like I've
missed out on some kind of fundamental
human joy by everyone I know that
doesn't like Christopher Robin just
freaking brings up Paddington to and I'm
like now I kind of wish fantasy didn't
come out so you can still appreciate
Christopher Robin cuz I appreciate
Christopher Robin yeah maybe it's just a
different movie and you're comparing
them because of similar aesthetics in
the film the description of annihilation
still made it sound like a movie the
average audience could latch onto yeah I
guess that's where my confusing part of
this list kind of comes with in terms of
annihilation and in terms of hereditary
because you guys are like they're not
mentioning here at all how a lot of
these were device it's very like I don't
get it
what is it about like to boil it down to
its a horror psychological thriller with
some sci-fi elements in it for
annihilation yeah like all rights so
much more to ever pitch it to be it's
like I think if you do a list like this
you have to acknowledge situations like
that for these types of movies like if
mother popped up on a list like this you
would have to be like well you know
pissed a lot of people off - yeah you
can't just be like you know what
traumatic psychological thriller some
people strongly disagree with it yeah
like calling this movie a monster film
weirdly it's advertised as that but I
didn't walk away thinking that at all
like has that element but it's just one
of the elements it's one it's one of the
many elements and it's more than just
combined John really I don't know it's
difficult thing to explain but to kind
of boil it down to a simplistic factor
where you pitch it in a way where the
average audience gonna hear this part of
the list or even go watch the trailer be
like I feel like I'm like no most people
walk out this movie don't know what's
going on also people will have left the
theater we saw people leaving the
theater because it's just too much
information sometimes to really digest
the couple's a couple of seats down from
us was just not into it at all and
hereditary was one we could kind of
digest and we were able to get most of
it I don't know like movies like
annihilation especially like the last
half of that movie is so thick and it's
themes and meaning loss of food a few
times yeah it's so heavy in that we're
watching the plot unfold because
confusing we're hereditary you can
pretty much watch that whole plot and
movie unfold to the very last scene it's
when it becomes confusing is in the last
few minutes of that movie yeah
annihilation the last half of that is I
don't even know what I'm watching tell
me what's happening first and then we
can make sense of Italy yeah I feel like
that would have been important to
acknowledge especially if you're talking
about the the I don't know the pinnacle
of films for the year should probably
have this sort of qualitative argument
and the potency argument addressed yeah
you know I don't have any issue at all
with putting it on your list or even
where you rank it I have no issue with
that it's just more like we didn't make
a lot of money Avengers infinity war you
know what's funny is we have never
talked about this film this is one movie
that I I'm dying to finally mention we
did see it and we give it an OK
recommendation we just watched it one
time didn't stay till the post-credits
scene we had to go
apparently Venom's gonna show up that's
what I hear I hear Tom
Hardy yeah is gonna be working with who
plays spider-man Tom Hiddleston yeah and
they're gonna be Hollywood yeah it's
gonna be great the best Hollywood Tom
and then Chris Pine you know who plays
Steve Rogers he's good dying
yeah I mean Chris Hemsworth who plays
I'm sorry I'm sorry
you know my my theory is about this this
is very diplomatic list I think they put
it here in the middle because they don't
actually think it's their number five
but they're like if we don't at least
put it in the top five we're gonna get
so much crap yeah bottom line you stuck
with your guns you made hereditary
number-one so even if you made this
number two or three you'd still get crap
don't you worry you guys don't worry
about the comment boxes I know what you
were trying to do I'm sure this is
probably closer number ten for you
number five I would say that infinity
Wars not my favorite movie of the year
but it's my favorite event movie of the
year
it certainly left a huge impression
certainly made you think about it a
little bit especially in terms of
cinematic landscape of this kind of yeah
it did make an enormous I mostly meant
for me I feel like of all of that type
of movie even The Incredibles too you
know or we were talking about Deadpool -
and stuff like that I feel like I'm all
the superhero movies that have come out
lately I feel like you could argue that
either Black Panther or infinity war
belongs somewhere on this list because
both of them caught everyone's attention
for a miss the people who care about
superhero stuff like Black Panther
tapped into so much culture and so much
celebration and I think that's a thing
worth addressing just like divisive
misses but infinity war really threw
down the gauntlet no pun intended in
terms of its scale and it's epic
dreariness you know and that pun was
intended which one - Colin yeah is a
bunch of words you could have gone with
seemed like a big like level up moment
the marvel universe where they did
something very bold and very broad and
very much like in oh yeah adding with
the universe of Comet legged they made
this big old universe and they've
crashed it all together and you know
that's a big event so yeah I'll go with
you on that like I feel like it belongs
perhaps on a list like this because of
that quality if the Oscars does the
popular film category I the infinity
world
infinity war deserves to say that I do
think Black Panther should get
recognition though for a Best Picture
nominee I'll say that - I don't think
infinity war should see like if if this
popular Film category works the way I
would like it to yeah affinity war would
win and Black Panther would get a
nomination for Best Picture yeah
actually according to Jason Dolan he
broke it down and apparently the very
first Oscars had a best like artistic
picture and a best popular picture Oscar
and what is Jason Dolan know thanks for
the new camera filming on by the way
quiet place is pretty good quiet place
is pretty bomb and III think this should
get a Best Picture honestly they're
taught for here I'm like I think oh so
she get nominated I I do pretty great
well I don't know if you're never really
here
best pitch or not I don't know I think
walking Phoenix will definitely not be
recognized by the end of the year it's
the way the world but I would like him
to get nominated and I would like oh
yeah I would like to see ramsey the chef
get nominated
cordon everybody a quiet place I think
should at least get some technical
design nominations if anything do I
believe it deserves directing nomination
100% I want even if you happy about even
if I happen to be one of those weird
cases where the picture doesn't get
nominated but the directing does I would
be I would be content with that because
like that's that's directing if dunkirk
the biggest recognition for dunkirk is
the technical achievement and quiet
place is such a technical achievement as
well on a different type of landscape
and a different type of scale and I
think John Krasinski absolutely deserves
to be nominated for that I think the
script is kind of
okay on that yeah that so much of what
makes that movie great is the
performance direction the vibe the
minimal sound although if you guys
haven't seen you were never really here
you gotta imagine films like taken
equalizer man on fire but just like that
the super realistic version are
sleepovers what if it was a character
study of this guy how messed up he is
seeing all this horrible side of life is
not in great shape he's what kind of
societal and you know how they always
had that cliche little girl they got a
rescue what if this was like a real
little crime yeah destroyed would she be
internally yeah crush do you want to
feel after a movie yeah it's it's
probably the best feel-good movie of the
year
yeah and hereditary same to me as well
like I would say same thing for that
what I said for a quiet sit back it's a
best director nada but not a best pitch
or not that would make sense to me yeah
cinematography without a doubt we should
be nominated for sure it's funny to me
that hereditary is number one because
there's something about this list that
makes me respect it now I know the big
comment boxes are all about infinity war
bears Black Panther and where it isn't a
list whatever to me sometimes we've
watched these list videos and you know
they're just trying to satisfy the
masses yeah
but for you to put a reddit area at
number one you're sticking to your own
opinion is just a good deal yeah you're
sticking to your own guns which i think
is a great call because at the end of
the day that's a divisive movie you know
sixty percent audience score does not
speak for the world but those are
thousands of people voting and sixty
percent is right there and we just made
it fresh on the audience for which to me
says something and it also got a pretty
low cinema score but a high critic
scored I feel like there are a lot of
great films that are divisive you know I
feel like that can be a telltale quality
of emeriti worth Raz nishan last Jedi
definitely the best hereditary also has
kind of what quiet place has but with
perhaps a a thicker script yes a much
more intricate like I I don't know if I
think it's a perfect score
but that I would know but I do think
that like if that even got nominated I
would be pretty happy about that yeah
it's like it is a bold piece of work in
every department across the board 100
yeah I feel like this list is like a
50-50 we're like half of it is for the
populace and half of it is like for the
film heads I haven't seen three of the
movies for that but seeing what they put
them like that makes sense to me yeah
there's always so much more to see and
there's always so much I haven't seen
yeah of all the stuff I've been like
hyper aware of I'm like yeah it seems
like a pretty good list this list came
out in July so it's 2018 so far but if I
were to make a list now I would probably
include crazy rich Asians on there I
really enjoy if you made it to the end
of this video I'm about to give you a
treat I'm gonna do a top 10 favorite
movies of the year it's all gonna be lie
I'm gonna try to talk about the divisive
films and the worst films but not crack
once on camera and try to give it actual
opinions yeah movie fighting
I need people to actually think I mean
this these shades will be high up there
solo will be high up there oh yeah we'll
be at the end of that video I will put
this footage in there very end after 10
minutes of black anyway guys thanks for
watching you guys are doing ok right now
I know we live in tough times
hey take that listen to shake it up any
order you know Putin's president right
now Jimmy Kimmel is taking over Conan
O'Brien show dad jokes not old or make
sense I feel like very foggy minor right
now hey listen why don't you do us a
favor if you made it this far you must
like us to some capacity please check us
out on patreon and help support the
channel yeah before I shut this channel
down myself there's just one button I
gotta click it's big and red baseball
word-processing hey check us out on here
subscribe click notification bells no
ring the bell ring it everyone's [ __ ]
saying that that makes it hurt it makes
no sense you can't ring the bell Bell on
this figurative what yeah bells ring I
still don't like the way people say that
again clicking is what you're actually
doing
look guys you can hear the computer when
I hit this Bell does it make a ring
sound that's what should be at the
bottom of the worst-ever list is this
just saying it's annoying where did you
get your clothes at the toilet store
alright guys thanks for watching bye
peace know it thanks Andrew is yay I
[ __ ] up the